If we have a rectangle with base length b
and height h, we know how to find his face.
His face will be simple
the base on the height.
The height base.
This is a rectangle face revision.
We simply multiply the base to the height.
Now let's look at a parallelogram.
In this parallelogram, the base also has a length b.
And we also have a height h.
When we talk about the height,
we do not mean the length of those countries that
at least in the way I've drawn them, are positioned diagonally.
We mean what's going to happen if you leave this country up here
and go straight down,
as you move at an angle of 90 degrees,
if you descend perpendicularly straight down,
you get to this country and that
will be the height.
In a situation like this when you have a parallelogram,
where you know the base and the height,
how much should his face be?
At first this may not seem so obvious,
as if we had a rectangle.
But we can do a bit of illustration that I think will help.
I'll take a piece from the face on the left,
this is the triangle on the left,
which helps to form the parallelogram,
and move it to the right.
And then we will see something incredible.
Here, I will take this,
I will take this little piece.
Actually let me do it a little better.
I'll take that piece right there.
I will cut it off and put it here.
It is still the same parallelogram,
but I will just move that part of his face.
Remember, we're just looking,
what is the space inside the parallelogram,
taking this area here
and I will move her to the right.
And what happened just now?
What's going on now?
Just to see if I can move it a little better.
What happened when I did this?
Look, now the shape looks exactly like the rectangle.
It just happened to take a small part
from the face of the parallelogram on the left
and we moved it to the right.
I rebuilt this rectangle,
therefore, they have the same person.
The face of this parallelogram,
this former parallelogram that was
before moving this triangle from left to right,
will also be the height base.
So the person here is also
the base on the height.
I just took this piece of the face that was there
and moved it to the right.
Yes, the face of a parallelogram,
let me make it look like a parallelogram again,
the face of a parallelogram will be simple,
if you have a height base,
will be just the height base.
So the faces of both figures
are just the height base.